there are four topics that we cover in
marketing innovation the first is
marketing toolkit where we give the
participants ten tools that we use and
in the courses that we teach here and
also with real entrepreneurs that allow
them to create new products and services
and enter new target markets the second
is a session that done under the VIPs
key leads and it's called creating
markets while creating products it takes
two to tango
and it's a really beautiful set of
examples of why and how you need to
simultaneously cultivate customers and
markets while you're developing the
product and then have a feedback loop
back and forth there she's not the only
person who's thinking this is important
we all do and certainly Steve Blank has
said something very similar in four
steps to the Epiphany with customer
development and we have great fondness
for Steve but so this the second piece
is very key the third piece is a case
study that I do about Tesla Motors to
help people think about how do we really
really understand the needs of different
segments for different products and then
how do we build what we call the whole
product that will really meet the needs
of those customers and then if we need
partners to help us build that whole
product who do we partner with how and
why so it's very practical and it
actually is built on real things that
have happened at Tesla and quite
interesting as well we have one of our
alumni from the course who now works at
Tesla who will offer some of her
perspective at the end of that session
and the fourth and I think most amazing
part of the whole series is a session
led by Linda Smith on marketing
measurement where she allows you to as a
participant you take either your company
or another company you're interested in
and you apply marketing measurement
tools to a real company to see how it's
doing this is an area that has become
increasingly important in the world of
internet social media where you can do a
lot of analytics it's an area that I
don't know anybody on earth
was more about it than manda and she
puts this information across and gives
you skills in a way that is very very
intuitive and we're just thrilled to
have it so those are the four pieces of
the course
we have a double objective for our
participants if they take this course
and learn what they can learn in it the
first is how to develop and deliver a
new product or service to the
marketplace and second is how do you
manage that product or service across
the technology adoption lifecycle and
around the world and we think that you
really need to be able to do both things
it's not just about getting a new
product in it's about managing it so it
becomes sustainable what I hope that
participants take away from this course
is that it's really really important to
figure out who your target markets are
and your customers and what they need
and get a product in their hands as
quickly as possible and because that's
what it takes to lay the foundation to
be successful what I also hope they take
away is that they can do it and they
should give it a try I hope that the
participants the the people that watch
this these sessions have the opportunity
to really understand what a driving
force marketing is in the innovation of
a company Marketing has a lot of
responsibilities but I think one of the
key areas that marketing can contribute
is actually innovation and it comes from
marketers really being rooted and
understanding what's the company trying
to accomplish what's going on in the
marketplace and then looking at how
marketing can help drive innovation